well oh c'mon almost from the beginning
but certainly from the 1920s forward
embodied toughness and golf for the last
60 plus years Oakland has been the best
course for identifying the best players
of their time and it's the only course
where every US Open winner since the
Second World War has been a multiple
major champion winner it has become
controversial it wasn't particularly
controversial at the time but people
have always liked this debate when
somebody says this is the greatest ever
they like to debate they have length in
the course in the last decade or so
simply to reflect the new technological
changes the balls go farther the club's
make them go farther the players are
also stronger the players are also as a
group more skilled and in order to
maintain what they call shot values from
generation to generation occasionally
have to alter the courses in some
significant way to adjust well my golf
history class at CMU is called the rise
of modern golf I've tried to make it a
course that fits with the broader social
and cultural political history
aspirations in the department we just
had 28 students from all over the campus
I was able to bring almost two dozen
students and oakmont went out of its way
to make the experience fantastic the
most spectacular thing walking the last
four holes of the golf course where the
corner will almost surely be decided
with a head golf professional and
walking those holes the students realize
they've never seen holes quite like that
they never felt turf like that under
their feet in the fairways they never
felt dreams like that under their feet
there's a tactile component to golf that
comes out spectacularly at oakmont so
this recent visit was really really
special
you